on a clear day you can see mountains all  across the horizon down there big  mountains can't see anything down there  now  look I just getting over the flats  though that might be a little yeah  it's time for me to get headed back to  the Brooks Range it's about a 60 mile  walk from the nearest road 200 miles  from town I live out here because I just  feel really well living out in the  mountains like this this is my favorite  place in the world  there's this veneer of civilization as  weighing people down and there's  something inside waiting to get out and  you get out here in the woods and you  can live it you can get primal as you  want to get it's different out here  touchdown we made it for hair look at  this looks like I went straight from  fall to winter okay miles thanks a lot  for the left leg sure have a good flight  back Thanks I love it when that plane  takes off and I just hear it  disappearing into the distance and I'm  all alone out here